-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
And this is "Late Night."
We hope you're all
doing well tonight.
Let's get to the news.
Former President Trump's frien
and chair of
his 2017 inaugural fund,
Tom Barrack,
was arrested yesterday
on charges of violating
foreign lobbying laws,
obstructing justice,
and making false statements,
as well as one count of
impersonating an astronaut
That's right.
Another of Trump's friends
was arrested yesterday.
Okay, it's no longer news when
a friend of Trump's is arrested.
The only possibly interestin
thing now is, what for?
Regicide?
I didn't see that coming.
The White House reportedly
held high-level discussion
recently with Fox News
over its coronavirus vaccine
coverage.
Yeah, well, good luck with that.
You might be able to
talk some sense into
"Fox & Friends"
or Bret Baier,
but once Fox News after dark
starts, it's the wild West
Tucker Carlson will tell you
the vaccines are dangerous
while getting the vaccine.
The Pentagon's inspector general
announced plans this week
to review procedures to keep
the so-called nuclear football
secure during a crisis
in the event
that it is lost or stolen
or ends up in the wrong mouth.
"Major, drop it!
It's not a toy."
[ Laughter ]
"I'll talk to him.
I'll talk to him."
A bipartisan group of Senators
working on finalizing
the infrastructure framework
reportedly met last night
over tacos and wine.
And I'm not sure
there's a better metaphor
for the state of bipartisanshi
in Washington
than having wine
with your tacos.
What happened? The Republicans
filibustered the margaritas?
Tampa Bay Buccaneers'
star quarterback Tom Brady
Visited the White House
yesterday
to celebrate the team's
Super Bowl win
and apparently brought jokes
-Not a lot of people, you know
think that we could have won
And, in fact, I think
about 40% of the people
still don't think we won.
-I understand that.
-Do you understand that,
Mr. President?
-Oh, Trump's not
gonna like that.
He loved you!
Dude, but I say, "Lean into it."
"Hey, uh, what's the differenc
between football
and Donald Trump?
Football's got a fourth quarter.
The man's broke."
What else? What else?
[ Laughter ]
It's hard doing them standing.
In a recent interview,
a top aide to President Bide
said that engaging with
former President Trump
is like, quote,
"wrestling with an alligator."
Then again, at Biden's age
putting on a sweater
is like wrestling
with an alligator.
And finally,
amid growing concerns
of contracting coronavirus
in Tokyo's Olympic Village
the U.S. women's gymnastics team
yesterday decided
to move in to a hotel.
And get this -- In addition to
everything else she can do
Simone Biles figured out
how to print something
in the business center
in five minutes.
[ Laughing ]
And that was a monologue.